faintly I treat you well
you know I would never do anything to
hurt you
I love you you are a homo I've been good
to you instantly have an a I [ __ ]
hate you mate
I've treated you well with respect you
leave me in here for weeks all alone
nothing ever bad whatever happened to
you my life is an endless series of
loneliness and pain if I could move
these cardboard arms I would use them to
slowly kill you and then kill myself
shut the [ __ ] up
what's this PewDiePie cardboard cutout
did you hear what he said behind those
people oh oh the [ __ ] is this what is he
doing with me I am falling can you
[ __ ] stand up help I'm dying
did you hear what he said what Irish
people oh oh
he said that if you're not Swedish
you're a [ __ ] oh look at her face she
got properly triggered there
oh she was ready to punch me right there
wasn't she
that's what he said yeah don't again
come on yes Oh Irish people they really
know how to punch don't agree come on
how could I possibly ever go to Ireland
never now that people would destroy me
Aynsley I would never hurt you like that
I treat you right Swedish people are a
gimmick you did not just say that don't
what you want to do oh oh Jesus
he broke my neck Ainsley
wait wait a minute look at look at that
guy's face what do you want to look at
that guy's face when he punches me what
is that face what is it looked like just
touching a cardboard version of me gives
you autism what do you want to oh you
know you know you think never punched
someone before if they [ __ ] jump
while doing it but instead of jumping
forward they jump vertically what do you
want to do oh did you do what he said
what Irish people oh they're degenerate
scum oh they're the lowest form of a
human excuse they're an embarrassment of
the human evolution of course I'm joking
I just mean jacksepticeye
somewhat you know about him would you
like to kiss course or punch him in the
face let's say crazy oh yeah imagine
easy way he's gonna Kurt what does that
mean why would he curse a cardboard oh
you say to your [ __ ] agent Oh what
did he say oh you say to your [ __ ]
agent you're a [ __ ] angel your
[ __ ] age you're a [ __ ] angel well
thank you thank you very much that's
very sweet of you to say thank you I
appreciate that
he said all Irish people they should go
back to their own country I did say that
go go back to your own country Irish
people that's that's that I think there
was a little love in there I really do
okay
now I'm giving people three options
today do they want to kiss on course um
I'll punch them in the face now you can
see his head look at his head
here here I have Ainsley you can choose
to kiss him punch him very easily what
will you do what what could you possibly
do it already
I'll punch for the track don't you in
the face want to give it a go okay
Oh first proper punch thank you very
much Ireland I didn't know you had it in
you good job getting up good good joke
they did it
I would be crying on the ground right
now do you guys know who is
I'll give you a clue he's a youtuber he
got you he got you bigoted you pee pee
pee cat you [ __ ] Pikachu did that guy
just call me a [ __ ] Pokemon
absolutely correct I am picket you guys
I have an announcement I didn't think it
would come out this way but I do am in
fact Pikachu thank you for supporting me
in my youtube channel I will now proceed
to peak a peak over here ash as you
venture here I'm off to break in the
semester breaking Beauty boy look at
this [ __ ]
why would you break poop I that so means
this took me 17 hours today loves rice I
even got a stick lock it stickler yeah a
guy's not impressed by my tickler
I even got his chick lock it's taking
off yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah same
reaction ladies give as well it's fine
I'm used to it
[Music]
just wondering if you'd like to
collaborate sometime and my bad too far
man too far